you stress murdering babies a lot but
when it comes to murdering babies kids
and everything in everyday shootings
that keep happening you say nothing so I
ask
why is it okay to murder babies when
it's regulating women but not regulating
guns no I say quite a lot about that
actually I think the crime is a terrible
problem and I think it's just awful that
liberals have funded and intentionally
installed liberal DA's who won't
prosecute violent criminals this has led
to an increase in violent crime but it's
not me and it's not my side that's
funding that sort of thing now you say
why wouldn't I want to regulate guns
guns are very regulated in the United
States as it is and I've yet to hear one
gun control proposal that would stop any
of these shooting incidents that people
talk about people focus on the
sensationalized ones from the news a
school shooting or a movie theater
shooting
no no proposed gun control legislation
of the last 30 years would have stopped
any of those